les smartphones ont chauffé ce mercredi
soir au circuit beltoise de trappes
comme depuis quatre ans le happy hour
business club a fait le plein mais cette
fois ci pour son anniversaire ce club
d'affaires qui propose chaque mois des
conférences sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines organisé une grande
soirée pour permettre aux entrepreneurs
de se retrouver après le travail
objectif les mettre en relation dans ce
club d'affaires vous avez rencontré
aussi bien le tout petit
les créateurs que des multinationales
style sodexo silk à l'aise puisqu'ils
etc et ou alors des professions
libérales des banques
il ya de tout une formule qui fonctionne
ils sont aujourd'hui plus de 160 à avoir
adhéré au club d'affaires c'est un
moment déjà convivial qui permet
effectivement de pouvoir rencontrer des
gens qu'on n'aurait pas forcément
l'occasion de rencontrer tout en ayant
ce côté un petit peur du réseau donc
ouais c'est vrai
donc le club hhbc me permet de
rencontrer les partenaires de futurs
collaborateurs des clients également
mais c'est surtout de ne plus être
isolés dans ce milieu entrepreneurial où
on est souvent voilà confronté à la
solitude donc c'est important ces genres
de pelles sont vraiment plus important
la prochaine réunion du club sera
programmée en septembre au golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines
le rendez-vous sera centré sur la
conférence comment maîtriser sa mémoire
d'éléphant la carte d'abonnement à
l'année est de 200 euros
[Musique]